[Musique]
est ce que votre groupe sanguin vous
rend plus ou moins susceptibles de
contracter la coved 19
une étude à ce sujet sème la confusion
cette étude réalisée par un groupe de
chercheurs chinois a porté sur une
cohorte de deux mille cent soixante
treize individus ayant contracté le
nouveau coronavirus dans les villes de
shenzhen
euan en somme en collectant des données
sur leur groupe sanguin dans les
comparant avec les types sanguins dans
la population générale
les chercheurs ont constaté chez les
personnes infectées une
sur-représentation des patients de type
a et al'inverse une meilleure réponse
immunitaire des patients de type oh mais
attendez un peu avant de vous inquiéter
ou de vous réjouir car quelques bémols
doivent être soulignés d'abord cette
étude n'a pas été évaluée de façon
indépendante par des pairs elle n'a donc
pas reçu le feu vert pour une
publication dans une revue scientifique
ensuite selon benoit barbeau professeur
au département des sciences biologiques
de l'uqam avec qui j'en ai parlé il y a
beaucoup de zones grises dans cette
étude beaucoup de facteurs autres que le
type sanguin qui ne semble pas avoir été
prises en considération et qui pourrait
avoir un impact sur l'interprétation des
résultats selon lui cela dit l'idée de
s'intéresser aux groupes sanguins des
patients atteints du nouveau camp à
virus mais ça ne sort pas de nulle part
l'ailier entre le virus du strass qui
sévit ans en appel en 2003 et sa
prévalence chez certains groupes
sanguins ont déjà été démontré dans une
étude de bien connu dans la littérature
médicale
cette étude là conclut que les individus
de type sanguin o ont une sensibilité
réduite à l'infection par le strass mais
malgré l'apparenté entre les deux
véreuses de strass en 2003 et le
coronavirus en 2020 il faudra absolument
attendre la validation des résultats
s'appliquant aux cornes virus actuel
avant d'affirmer quoi que ce soit sur
son impact sur les différents groupes
sanguins continuons donc de nous
intéresser à la recherche scientifique
qui se fait sur le nouveau coronavirus
mais attend donc les résultats de ces
analyses pas toutes les étapes de
validation nécessaire avant de sauter
aux conclusions
n'hésitez pas à consulter mon article à
ce sujet sur notre site web
et si vous avez des doutes sur les
conclusions d'études portant sur la
copie de 19
et le virus qui la cause faites-nous
ceni par courriel ou via notre groupe
facebook
salut